john batiste john batiste john baptiste
11 nominations what does it mean to you
to have the most nominations of any
artist on this planet
[Music]
we made these albums
in the pandemic to come out of it and
receive the recognition just brings me
to tears i'm so moved stephen colbert
you know who's going to get a raise now
justin bieber trails the late show band
leader tying dozier cat and her with
eight nominations let's go
a grammy first this year 10 nominees in
the big four categories and up for all
of them including best new artists
olivia rodrigo who racked up seven total
nods after winning best new artist at
sunday's amas the 18 year old is up
against the cma's new artist of the year
jimmy allen after his tearful win just
for the record these ain't new tears
they leftover tears another big matchup
to look for when the grammys air live on
cbs january 31st i'm really happy for
you i'm let you finish yep taylor swift
and kanye going head-to-head for album
of the year but yay who's recently been
all about ending feuds you did leak
drake's address correct it's on google
maps okay is also up against drake for
best rap album after they announced a
reunion concert and then there's this
donda collab finally free
the weeknd who said he was boycotting
the grammys wound up getting a nod today
for his song with west
we're very happy to be celebrating our
grammy win tonight previous duet winners
tony bennett and lady gaga are nominated
again for love for sale which marks the
95 year old's final studio recording
tony's always ready
and this triple nominee is riding high
jasmine sullivan of course any
nomination is a blessing and i've been
nominated it 12 times
we caught up with the r b singer at the
soul train awards where she's up for six
nods but as far as grabbing grammy gold
if i win that'll be even more awesome
you know what would be even more awesome
is if you perform i'm putting that out
there right now i need to see a
performance i would love it
listen that was my soundtrack of the
summer so i know she's gonna pick up
some awards okay the soul train awards
air this sunday on b-e-t